Here to help us is a snake expert.
It's Steve Lengen,
also known as the New Jersey Snake Man.
(audience clapping)
Now is that a moniker you might have put in a Post-it
on your mirror when you were younger?
Totally, yeah, absolutely.
I've been into it since I was four, so definitely.
Oh, so you found your path.
Yeah, I did.
There was some curves along the way, but yeah, for sure.
There always is.
For sure.
Well, I'm excited for you
to teach us about different snakes.
I'd like to learn about them and their personalities.
So, first, we're gonna get into this little, cute snake.
What is its name?
So his name is Carrot Cake, and this is a corn snake.
And Craig is going to get down with the corn snake.
There you go.
He liked the dating profile.
Is there anything we need to know about this snake?
Likes, dislikes, habits.
So they like to eat rodents.
They live in pine forests for the most part.
How big do they get?
So that's an adult male.
They get to be about three feet as males.
The females are actually bigger than the males,
so they can top out around five.
The females are bigger
than the males, huh?
Oh, they are, yep.
(audience clapping)
Interesting.
Bigger and stronger.
All right, give me one thing
that would surprise us about this snake, one detail.
Oh, it's actually the most popular pet snake in the world.
Oh, wow.
That's a good detail.
Now, Craig, will you give us a detail
about "Killing It," one per snake?
Yes, yes.
I'm a python hunter in "Killing It."
Sorry, kid.
I do it to raise money,
because I'm about that American dream.
I love it, okay, next,
we have a boa constrictor named Big Wig.
Oh, yeah!
Is that the one you feel that I might be a match with?
I mean, he is an outdoorsy guy.
Yeah, give me his dating profile.
For sure, if he had arms,
he would be into kayaking for sure.
I love kayaking!
He's perfect.
So it's a match made in heaven.
May I?
Absolutely.
In your hands or on your shoulders?
There we go, all right.
Maybe I could Britney this up.
Oh, for sure.
(audience cheering)
I'm in.
Tell me a detail about my future boyfriend.
He's a really cheap date.
He would only eat probably four to six times a year.
And is it like a muskrat?
Does he eat something really large when he eats?
Basically, in the wild, they'll eat the biggest thing
that'll fit in their mouth.
So it's kinda like Thanksgiving.
Every time, yep.
Loosen their belt, head back and go to sleep.
Now, Craig, will you tell us another detail
about maybe your relationships with snakes on the show?
You seem very comfortable.
Were you always comfortable with snakes?
No, you know what?
I was in Australia in about 2016 with my band
and that's where I got over my fear of snakes.
Because I was about to take a picture
with my band member who had a snake
and I was gonna act like I was scared to get close.
And then, I accidentally I touched the snake
and it felt so amazing.
And I'm letting him put it around my neck.
And I was like, "This snake means you no harm.
You've been lying to by the 'Bible' and Indiana Jones."
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
Alright, let's bring out our third snake.
This is gonna give you some Britney vibes.
She made this one famous at the VMAs.
It's a Python.
Yowza.
(audience clapping)
Wow.
These guys are from Southeast Asia
in Myanmar, used to be Burma.
So they like it real warm.
And they tend to spend a lot of time
in sort of swampy areas.
I mean, he is really gorgeous
and I was just telling everybody at the commercial break
how much yellow is the color of our show,
because it's such a optimistic color.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, I'll take in.
Oh, I feel like I just swiped left on one
and right on another.
That's okay, they're both outdoorsy.
I feel like a two timer.
Whoa-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
I don't know how to describe this sensation.
Craig?
Yeah.
Can you describe the sensation
of manhandling a very large snake?
(audience clapping)
I mean, 'cause this is,
boy, is this different even than the boa.
It's like being tickled by a hot dog.
Well, would you like a giant kielbasa
that could possibly like strangle you?
Sure.
Can we trade?
Is that possible?
Yeah, yeah.
Let's make it happen.
Whoa, I just want everyone to note the leg.
Just want everyone to note the rapid.
Really there is like the sense
that this could kill me
so quickly, so fast.
Where you going, buddy, where you going?
But like it's exciting,
'cause I'm trusting so much that it won't,
but there is no question that it could.
Could I?
Oh, sure, absolutely.
(Craig choking playfully)
(audience laughing)
You guys, one last detail, Craig.
What is the latest Post-it that you would put
on your mirror or affirmation for yourself right now?
I would say, "It's yours."
(audience clapping)
Well, Craig and Steve,
thank you so much
for what has been such a beautiful,
fun, awesome, dope segment.
This is my kind of jam, really and truly.
My pleasure, thank you.
Thank you.
And "Killing It" premieres today on Peacock!
Get it while it's hot, it is so much fun.
Craig Robinson, I have loved you
for so long.
Love you too.
May we just live in a world with more Craig Robinson,
and then it can be ours.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)